MSNBC host Chris Matthews has had a
terrible week or ten days and he is now
abruptly quit on live television last
night claiming he's retiring to clear a
path for the younger generation
coincidentally happening after two of
the most embarrassing on-air Fiasco's of
his career combined with sexual assault
sexual harassment allegations let's
first look at Chris Matthews quitting
then we'll look at what led up to it and
discuss whether we believe his
explanation the explanation does
reference the sexual harassment
allegations against him let me start
with my headline tonight I'm retiring
this is the last hard ball at MSNBC and
obviously this isn't for lack of
interest in politics as you can tell
I've loved every minute of my 20 years
as host of hardball
every morning I read the papers and I'm
gung ho to get to work not many people
have had this privilege I love working
with my producers and the discussions we
have over how to report the news and I
love having this connects with you the
good people who watch I've learned who
you are bumping into you on the sidewalk
or at waiting at an airport and say
hello you're like me I hear it from your
kids and grandchildren who say my dad
loves you or my grandmother loves her my
husband watched it till the end
well after conversation with MSNBC I
decided tonight will be my last hardball
so let me tell you why the younger
generation is out there ready to take
the reins we see them in politics in the
media and fighting for their causes they
are improving the workplace we're
talking here about better standards than
we grew up with fair standards a lot of
it has to do with how we talk to each
other compliments on a woman's
appearance that some men including me
might have once incorrectly thought were
okay we're never okay not then is
certainly not today and for making such
comments in the past I'm sorry so he
says it's time there's a younger
generation coming things are changing
it's my time but he does reference those
allegations against him from women of
sexual harassment and he does apologize
for it but there's more to this story
because the day that Jewish candidate
Bernie Sanders won the Nevada caucus
Matthew said it was like the Nazis
invading France
take a look I'm reading last night about
the fall of France
in the summer of 1940 and the general
renault calls up Churchill and says it's
over insurances of hot can it be you got
the greatest army in Europe how could it
be over he said it's over so I had that
print suppressed feeling I can't be as
wild as Carville but he is damn smart
and I think he stand right on this one
that led to calls for his resignation
and he apologized for saying that then
this past weekend Chris Matthews got
black politicians mixed up mistaking
black Republican senator Tim Scott for
black Democratic challenger Jamie
Harrison and it was just as
cringe-worthy as you imagine Jamie I see
you standing next to the guy you're
gonna beat right there maybe maybe maybe
Lindsey Graham Scott Sims guy Jamie
who's that that's Tim Scott Hey Oh what
am I saying
big mistake mistaken identity sir sorry
tell me how you gonna be done and then
the cherry on top yes as Chris Matthews
alluded to comments to women that he has
made he did indeed get accused of sexual
harassment this week as well so Chris
Matthews goes out quickly there were
countless calls for him to resign and he
is immediately retiring a sort of
practical question who replaces him we
don't know there are reports that MSNBC
has been speaking to Shepard Smith who
left Fox News months ago I guess it
can't have been a year probably six
months ago I don't remember time is a
weird thing in the Trump era Shep Smith
left Fox News after very public
disagreements with other hosts and with
the Trump propaganda machine and there
are discussions about could Shep Smith
maybe have a role to play in the future
of MSNBC so that's the story merely a
quick update with so much going on today
it's Super Tuesday so many other things
I don't want to dwell on this story much
more now but very quickly after three
very bad public incidents two on air one
of us sexual harassment allegations
Chris Matthews out at MSNBC I don't
think a lot of people in my audience are
particularly
torn up over Chris Matthews leaving but
if I am wrong indeed let me know I want
to tell you about one of our sponsors
magic spoon remember breakfast cereal
when I was growing up breakfast cereal
was a really big part of my Saturday
mornings then I became an adult and
realized I don't want to be eating all
that sugar I don't want to be eating all
that junk
and now breakfast has gotten much more
boring magic spoon is a new cereal
company that has discovered how to
recreate your favorite childhood cereals
with zero sugar 12 grams of protein and
just three grams of net carbs per
serving they offer four flavors based on
the classics cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry plus the variety pack which
lets you try them all
magic spoon spent more than a year
working with the best food scientists
and chefs to recreate the taste and
texture of that classic sugary cereal
but it tastes so incredible you would
never guess that it was healthy its keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
low carb and GMO free you've got to try
it to believe it because it tastes great
my favorite of course cocoa cocoa go to
magic spoon dot-com slash Pakman grab a
variety pack and try it today make sure
to use the promo code Pakman at checkout
to get free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it is backed
with a 100% happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason you'll get
a refund no questions asked that's magic
spoon comm slash Pakman promo code
Pakman for shipping